it is
literally the wild west this is an
absolutely appalling situation
how can they say that you're qualified
to do these treatments
after such a short spell social media is
packed with
aesthetic practitioners promoting their
businesses and more and more companies
are offering training courses
teaching students how to perform
procedures like botox and filler
but the area is almost completely
unregulated
completely unacceptable practice it
takes a considerable amount of time
and practice to inject safely i felt
absolutely
frightened to death i can't offer this
service to people
when it's me it's gonna pick up the
pieces
like most young women my age i spend a
lot of time scrolling through social
media
but recently i noticed my explore pages
were absolutely filled with videos of
people getting dermal filler and botox
and as i scrolled i noticed just how
many of these businesses offering these
procedures
also had their own training centers
think about it as a non-surgical buccal
fat pad removal
non-surgical cheek lift but there are
currently
no laws restricting who can give these
procedures and who can teach others how
to do them
and while there are some great providers
others are offering training in botox
and filler that falls
far below recommended standards
i've got in touch with a former nurse
last year she went on a one-day botox
and filler training course but she left
feeling
completely unprepared she's asked us not
to use her name so
we'll call her paula i felt worried and
then i got home and i tried to sort of
reflect back on the training and
thinking about well
how do you do this area how do you
inject it so what dosage do you use
i felt absolutely frightened to death
i thought i can't go out there and like
offer this service to people
when it's me it's gonna pick up the
pieces when anything goes wrong because
i haven't got anything to back me up
paula's course was aimed at students
with a background in healthcare but she
says that each person only had around 45
minutes to practice because of the size
of the group
the course was run by a doctor there was
um
cheek fillers lecturer that had my group
told me that we shouldn't be
really being taught that because it was
class more of an advanced technique
but there was teach us anyway so i only
got to observe that i never got to do it
paula left with a certificate that said
she was qualified to give invasive
treatments that she had never fully
practiced before
the course cost her 925 pounds
and paula is not the only one we've seen
countless messages on social media of
people discussing their poor training
experiences
students alleging that they were trained
in a garden that they didn't even get to
inject our models before they left
and even students alleging that they
were not taught how to deal with the
potentially
life-threatening complications that can
result from these procedures
i attended an academy which was horrific
and left out a load of vital information
the girls who qualified while we were
there started teaching the classes and
pretended they had loads of experience
it was embarrassing so lovely to read
this i've had a really good experience
with the academy i paid a lot of money
too
i felt totally unsupported since
starting with them so much so
i've left the course
the number of aesthetic training centers
has grown significantly in recent years
and social media is one of the main ways
companies promote their services
sky news analyzed 100 facebook business
pages for these companies
and found that nearly half had been set
up since the beginning of 2020
and nearly three quarters have been
created since the beginning of 2019.
[Music]
david signs who chairs the industry's
voluntary regulator
says they've been receiving up to 20
complaints about poor training for the
past
two years it takes a considerable amount
of time
and practice to inject safely
subcutaneously
or intramuscularly of course but that
cannot be done in the absence not just
technique but a real knowledge of the
potential risks
we asked him what every course ought to
be providing as a minimum
understanding of anatomy and physiology
infection control standards injection
techniques
product knowledge and complication
management
it's appalling absolutely appalling if
things go wrong and expectations aren't
managed
then this can cause very deep wounding
with regard to psychological and
emotional trauma
so that's one big area that occurs the
other
are physical symptoms and physical
challenges i mentioned the issue of
vascular occlusion where lips as we've
seen can be very swollen
the face can actually be distorted but
also it can lead to potential
paralysis muscular paralysis due to poor
injection
technique so how easy is it to get on
one of these courses
i contacted eight different training
companies about their beginners courses
in injectables
i was clear that i had no relevant
experience whatsoever
four of them offered me a place provided
that some online learning was completed
beforehand
one told me i'd get an instant fast
track to basic dermal filler and
foundation fine lines and wrinkles
another offered me the same which could
be completed
in six days in total
all of the courses took under a week to
complete
a parliamentary inquiry into the
non-surgical cosmetic treatment industry
is due to reports soon the group feels
that the only solution
is for the government to intervene we
need proper regulation
appropriate regulation i'm not saying
that we should regulate the whole
industry out of existence
because there's a lot of good people out
there there's mainly it's an industry
that is run by women for women
on the whole and this is providing a
good
opportunity for women to be able to
employ other people and to earn a
business
but until that happens they say it's
unlikely the problem will go away
the consumer is facing the situation
where
quite frankly they could be in danger
because somebody's messing about with
their
face injecting them um maybe incorrectly
maybe correctly
but they're really putting themselves in
dangers when they walk into a place but
someone's wearing a white car
there's a certificate up on the wall
they feel at ease and they shouldn't
i think the only way really to protect
like the general public and protect like
the practitioners because like if you
did something wrong
you know and your insurance invalidates
itself then
you're reliable for what you've done